السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته اهلا بكم
الى نشره الرابعه من الرياض نبداها
بالعناوين
رائعه على جميع انشطته وامتداداته
الاجراميه اينما كانت السعوديه تشدد على
مواجهه الارهاب بكافه اشكاله وتؤكد على
تجفيف منابع تمويل داعش
بيان خليجي امريكي يؤكد على اهميه الجهود
المشتركه للعمل على خفض التصعيد في
المنطقه
ما هو الواقع الف ميجا واط ستكون من نقطه
الارتباط محطه عرعر بمحطه بدء تنفيذ مشروع
الربط الكهربائي الخليجي مع العراق عبره
ستنقل نحو الف ميجا وات من الطاقه الى
جنوب العراق
ومن ملفات فاتنه المتنوعه في الرابعه ايضا
النائب الكويتي محمد هايف يعلن اعادته كل
تشريعات لجنه القيم من خلال مجلس الامه
الجديد
منها وتامنها
بعد شائعات حول وفاته ابن الشاعر السعودي
خلف بن هدال ينفي الشائعات ويقول والدي
بخير
مساء الخير اكد وزير الخارجيه السعودي
الامير فيصل بن فرحان في افتتاح الاجتماع
الوزاري للتحالف الدولي ضد داعش في الرياض
اكد على ان المملكه ستبذل كل جهد لملاحقه
تنظيم داعش وفكره اينما كان ودعا بن فرحان
دول التحالف الى تحمل مسؤوليتها واستعاده
مواطنيها من عناصر داعش والعمل على منع
تنظيم من استغلال اي فرصه للعوده من جديد
لدي فقط ملاحظه سريعه من المحبط وغير
المقبول اطلاقا ان تواصل بعض الدول
المتقدمه والثريه التنصل من مسؤوليتها في
استعاده مواطنيها ورفع هذا العبء عن
البلدان الاكثر تضررا من داعش لذلك اود ان
اقول لتلك البلدان يجب ان تتحمل
مسؤولياتكم باعتباركم جزءا من هذا التحالف
فهذا يعني ان نعمل معا وان نقف مع بعضنا
البعض وهذه نقطه اساسيه نحتاج جميعا الى
معالجتها
كما اكد وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير
فيصل بن فرحان على حرص المملكه على
استقرار الدول والذي استغل داء تنظيم داعش
اراضيها من اجل تنفيذ مخططاته التدميريه
ومنها سوريا والعراق
المملكه على استقرار الدول التي استغلها
هذا التنظيم اراضيها من اجل تنفيذ مخططاته
التدميريه ومنها سوريا والعراق ونشيد بما
بذله العراق من جهود حاسمه وتنسيق المستمر
مع التحالف الدولي للقضاء على التنظيم
وتقديرا لجهود اخوتنا في العراق فقد ساهمت
المملكه في تمويل مشاريع اعاده الاعمار في
العراق
من جانبه دعا وزير الخارجيه الامريكي الى
تسريع عمليات استعاده مسلحي داعش الاجانب
المعتقلين في المخيمات في سوريا واشار
بلينكن الى ان الوضع يزداد سوءا في منطقه
الساحل والغرب الافريقي مع تصاعد العمليات
الارهابيه وتسجيل الكثير من الضحايا كما
لفت الى ان الولايات المتحده تراقب
الاخطار الناشئه لمحاولات داعش الى العوده
من جديد في افغانستان
تعتبر اعاده المقاتلين الارهابيين الاجانب
وافراد عائلاتهم الى اوطانهم امرا بالغ
الاهميه لتقليل عدد سكان مخيمات النازحين
مثل الهول ومراكز الاحتجاز التي تضم ما
يقرب من عشره الاف مقاتل 2000 منهم من دول
اخرى غير سوريا والعراق ان الفشل في اعاده
المقاتلين الاجانب الى اوطانهم يزيد مخاطر
حملهم السلاح مره اخرى ومحاوله استعاده ما
يسمى بخلافه داعش وايضا ترهيب المجتمعات
التي نعمل على استقرارها واعاده بنائها
وكذلك احتمال تهديد اوطادنا
من الرياض ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
هنصفيان اهلا بك معنا هاني على نشره
الرابعه اذا بدايه كيف تسير مجريات
الاجتماع وهل من تصريحات اخرى مرتقبه في
الدقائق او الساعات القادمه
نعم اهلا بك فاطمه واهلا بمشاهدي قناه
العربيه نعم انتهى بالفعل اجتماع الوزاري
والدولي لمؤتمر التحالف ضدها داعش والذي
حضره 84 دوله وكذلك خمس منظمات معتمده
منها جامعه الدول العربيه وكذلك حلف
الاطلسي وكذلك الانتربول وكذلك اخرى عموما
هذا الاجتماع انتهى وبعدها او تلام هناك
اجتماعات ثنائيه بين وزراء خارجيه بعض
الدول منها الافريقيه وكذلك اجتماع سمو
وزير الخارجيه الامير فيصل بن فرحان مع
كذلك بعض الدول في غرب افريقيا هذه
اللحظات القادمه سوف يكون المؤتمر الصحفي
والذي سوف ننتظره في هذه اللحظات من داخل
هذه القاعه والذي سوف يكون بحضور سمو وزير
الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل بن فرحان
وكذلك وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني ممكن
هناك وسائل اعلام الدوليه واقليميه وكذلك
محليه هي في انتظار هذه اللحظات القادمه
طبعا سوف يكون هناك بعد هذا المؤتمر
الصحفي هو بيان رسمي يوضح ايضا منوقشها من
خلال هذا الاجتماع ولكن عندما نتحدث عن
بدايه هذا الاجتماع والذي بدا فيه تمام
الساعه التاسعه صباحا بالتوقيت المحلي
السعودي من كلمه لسمو وزير الخارجيه
السعودي الامير فيصل بن فرحان والذي تحدث
عن دور المملكه بانها تؤمن بان السبيل
للامن والاستقرار والتنميه والازدهار
يتطلب مواجهه الجماعات والفكر المتطرف
منها تنظيم داعش وكذلك حديث انتوني بلينكن
الذي تلا كلمه سمو وزير الخارجيه السعودي
وعندما تحدث ان الحرب لم تنتهي ضد داعش
واي يعني ان مازال التنظيم يقوم
بعملياته وتهديداته على مستوى العالم
وتحديدا في هذه الفتره هي في داخل قاره
افريقيا وفي بعض دول افريقيا وهو ما دفع
ايضا او ايضا ما صرح فيه واعلن عنه سمو
وزير الخارجيه عن انضمام المملكه لرئاسه
مجموعه التركيز المعنيه بشان الافريقي
لمواجهه مخاطر هذا التنظيم الارهابي اي
داعش عموما نحن ما زلنا ننتظر اللحظات
القادمه وكذلك المؤتمر الصحفي الذي سوف
يكون على شاشه العربيه خلال النصف القادمه
وسوف يكون ايضا هناك طبعا لعدد من الاسئله
من قبل
في يعني حضروا على من مجريات هذا المؤتمر
الصحفي وكل تصريحات التي ستخرج منه شكرا
جزيلا لك مراسل العربيه نصفيان
اكد وزراء خارجيه دول التعاون الخليجي
ووزير الخارجيه الامريكي
في بيان مشترك على اهميه جهود خفض التصعيد
في المنطقه والمساهمه في الاستقرار
والازدهار على الصعيد الاقليمي وشدد
الجانبان على اهميه دعم الحقوق والحريات
وجهود التصدي لاي تهديد ضد امن السفن كما
شدد الوزراء على اهميه مواجهه الارهاب
والتطرف العنيف في جميع انحاء العالم وعبر
البيان الخليجي الامريكي عن الالتزام
بالتوصل الى سلام عادل ودائم وشامل في
الشرق الاوسط وذلك وفقا لحل الدولتين ورفض
اي اجراءات احاديه وخاصه في القدس وشدد
البيان على ضروره التزام ايران بالتعاون
الكامل مع الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
ورحب باستئناف العلاقات الدبلوماسيه بين
السعوديه وايران اما بشان السودان اشاد
البيان بجهود الرياض و واشنطن عبر منبر
جده
للوصول الى اتفاق لوقف اطلاق النار بين
الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع مشددا على
انه لا حل عسكري للازمه
بدات دول الخليج والعراق اليوم بتنفيذ
مشروع الربط الكهربائي مع شبكه جنوب
العراق والذي يتوقع تشغيله نهايه العام
المقبل بدوره كشف المتحدث باسم وزاره
الكهرباء العراقيه احمد موسى كشف للعربيه
ان الربطه الكهربائي مع السعوديه سيغذي
العراق بنحو الف ميجا وات في المرحله
الاولى عن طريق محطه عرعر الحدوديه السيد
الوزير اليومي يحقق زياره الى الدمام
بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه حيث مقر هيئه
الربط الخليجي هنالك رابط خليجي هنالك ربط
اخر يختلف عن الرابط الخليجي اللي هو
الرابط السعودي كنا قد حققنا زياره
التقينا وزياده الطاقه السعودي وضعنا
النقاط احيانا مسارات الخطوط درسنا نقاط
الربط وبالتالي الحديث عن المرحله الاولى
هو بواقع الف ميجا وات ستكون من نقطه
الارتباط محطه عرعر بمحطه اليوسفيه وايضا
هذا المشروع باطار ترويع مصادر الطاقه
وتحقيق استقراريه الشبكه
من الخبر ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه عبد
المحسن الحربي اهلا بك معنا عبد المحسن
اذا ما تفاصيل هذا الربط الكهربائي الذي
بدا تنفيذه بين السعوديه والعراق ودول
الخليج طبعا
نعم فاطمه بالفعل هنالك مسارين يتم العمل
عليها الى على ربط الخليج وكذلك السعوديه
بالعراق مسار من شمال السعوديه بالاضافه
الى هناك محطه اخرى هي محطه الوفره في
الكويت والتي سيتم اليوم الاحتفاء ببدء
تنفيذ هذا المشروع هنا في الخبر بحضور
واسع لاسيما من وزير الكهرباء
العراقي بالاضافه الى
وزير الطاقه السعودي الامير عبد العزيز بن
سلمان بالاضافه الى الامين العام لدول
مجلس التعاون الخليجي ومن خلاله سيتم
البدء رسميا بتنفيذ هذا المشروع الذي
سينقل الكهرباء الخليجيه وتحديدا منظومه
الربط الكهربائي الخليجي عبر هيئه الربط
الكهربائي الخليجي التي تستفيد من الفائض
من كافه دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي وتم ربط
كافه دول مجلس خلال السنوات الماضيه اليوم
الهيئه والدول التي تعاون الخليجي تستعد
للانتقال خارج منظومه دول مجلس التعاون
الخليجي والمره الاولى عبر العراق عبر هذه
عبر هذا المشروع الذي سيبدا تنفيذه بدءا
من اليوم حيث الاحتفاليه ببدء تنفيذ هذا
المشروع وسيتم الانتهاء منه في نهايه
العام القادم تحديدا في ديسمبر بتكلفه
اجماليه بلغت 280 مليون دولار حيث سيتم
تمويل هذا المشروع من عدد من الصناديق
التنمويه الخليجيه وهنا نتحدث عن صندوق
قطر للتنميه بالاضافه الى صندوق الكويتي
وهكذا تعمل الهيئه على تنميه او تمويل هذه
المشاريع التي تقوم بها بالاضافه الى
مشاريع اخرى تقوم بها
للتزويد وايضا تكثيف الكهرباء
والتكثيفه عبر عدد من محطات سواء كان في
الكويت لرفض هذا المشروع الى العراق
بالاضافه الى مشاريع اخرى فاطمه بالاضافه
الى ذلك نتحدث عن
مراحل التي سيتم العمل فيها من خلالها على
ربط المشروع الرابطه الكهربائي الخليجي
بالعراق
المرحله الاولى هي هذه التي سيتم فيها نقل
500 ميجا وات عبر هذا المشروع بسعه نقل
تتسع الى 1800 بالاضافه الى مرحله اخرى
نتحدث عن الف ميجا واط والمرحله الثالثه
وهي الاهم التي وصفها وزير الكهرباء
العراقي وهي بنقل الكهرباء الخليجيه عبر
الاراضي العراقيه الى تركيا من ثم الى
اسواق جديده هنالك في اوروبا وهذا
قال عنه مختصون عراقيون بانه سيرفض العراق
بمبالغ جديده او استثمارات جديده عبر هذا
المشروع بالاضافه لذلك مشروع الثنائي ما
بين السعوديه والعراق عبر مشروع عرعر
اليوسفيه هذه المحطه التي ستولد تقريبا
مئه الف
ميغاوات وايضا هناك مشروع لاكوى باور
بداخل العراق لتوليد ما يقرب على الف ميجا
وات عبر
عبر توليد الكهرباء عبر الطاقه الشمسيه
فاطمه شكرا لك من الخبر مراسل العربيه عبد
المحسن الحربي على كل هذه المعلومات
عقب على النتائج مجلس الامه الكويتي وفوزه
بمقعد عن الدائره الرابعه اعلن النائب
الكويتي حمد هايف المطيري في تصريحات
مصوره له اعلن اعاده كل ما تم تقديمه من
تشريعات عبر لجنه القيم ومعالجه الظواهر
السلبيه خلال المجلس السابق والذي ابطل
بقرار من المحكمه الدستوريه وقال النائب
المطيري بانه سيتم طرح كل ما يتعلق
بالاخلاق والهويه الاسلاميه من خلال
اللجنه تصريحات المطيري اعادت للواجهه
الجدل حول وثيقه القيم التي اعلنت عنها او
اعلن عنها العام الماضي وحظيت بدعم عدد من
النواب من خلال التزامهم بتطبيق قوانين
الشريعه الاسلاميه ومنع ما اعتبروها
مخالفات شرعيه في البلاد الوثيقه المثيره
للجدل والتي اطلقها الناشط الاسلامي عبد
الرحمن النصار وحظيه بدعم الكويتي عثمان
الخميس طلبت بتعديل قوانين منع الاختلاط
في الجامعه والفصل الك امل بين مباني
ومطاعم الطلاب والطالبات وتجريم النوادي
والمسابح المشتركه في الفنادق كما طالبت
الوثيقه مواجهه مسم- ما اسمته بالابتدال
الاخلاقي وعرض الاجساد في الاماكن العامه
ينضم الينا من الكويت المحلل السياسي محمد
السبتي اهلا بك معنا سيد محمد في نشره
الرابعه يعني
وثيقه اثارت الكثير من الجدل واعاده
الحديث عن هذه الوثيقه الى ماذا يشير
برايك
يعني في ظني اننا يجب ان نناقش هذه
الوثيقه من ناحيتين من ناحيه الاولى ما
احتوت عليه من مناداه ومبادئ يريدون فرضها
على المجتمع وهذه المنادى وهذه المبادئ
وهذه المطالبات تقبل النقاش تقبل الرفض
وتقبل القبول
الناحيه الثانيه التي يجب ان نناقشها في
هذه الوثيقه هي احقيه هؤلاء النواب
الاسلاميين او الكتل الاسلاميه في مثل هذه
المناداه في ظني ان من حق هؤلاء النواب
اسلاميين كانوا او يعني متعاونين مع
الاسلاميين او منضمين تحت لواء
الجماعات الاسلاميه من حق هؤلاء ان ينادوا
مثلها مثل هذه القيم ان يتنادوا فيما
بينهم على توقيع مثل هذه الوثائق هذا حق
مقفول وليس لاحد في المجتمع ان يرفض مثل
هذه المناداه اذ قد وقعت في الكويت على
مدار سنوات طويله عده من الوثائق تنادى
فيها اصحاب المهن مثلا احيانا تنزل فيها
اصحاب بعض المطالبات سواء كانت شعبويه او
غير شعبويه لذلك في ظني ان الاسلاميين قد
اوجوا بشيء من الرفض وهو غير مقبول غير
مقبول التحجير على النواب الاسلاميين
التنادي فيما بينهم في بعض المطالبات الا
في قصيد محمد يعني الى اي مدى يستخدم
البعض هذه الوثيقه ربما للضغط على الحكومه
بشكل او باخر
لنكون صراحه عموم المحتوت عليه على عليه
هذه الوثيقه لا تعدو ان تكون مطالبات يعني
تدغدغ مشاعر الاسلاميه ليس الا يعلم
الجميع بما فيه من وقع مثل هذه الوثيقه ان
كثير من هذه المطالبات غير قابله للتنفيذ
قد تكون هي مجال للتفاوض مع الحكومه
وتبادل الادوار فيما بينهم والمصالح
وتبادل الادوار والمصالح مع باقي الكتل
لكن الكل يعلم ان مثل هذه المطالبات غير
قابله للتحقيق بل سيده الفاضله لنكن صرحاء
كذلك ان عموم النواب الاسلاميين في الكويت
وفي غير الكويت كذلك انما يمارسون هذه
العمليه الانتخابيه اداء للواجب هم
جماعه الاسلاميه ترفض هذه العمليه
الديمقراطيه برايك المشهد العام في الكويت
فيها تحقيقا لبعض لا يستدعي مثل هذه
الوثيقه والمطالبات بتشكيل لجنه خاصه
بالمظاهر السلبيه في المجتمع
لا بلا شك لا يستدعي ليس هناك ما يدعو الى
مثل هذه المناداه الا مثل ما قلت هي
مدغدغه مشاعر يعني الناخب الاسلامي
والمحافظين اذا صح التسميتهم هذا هو يعني
طرحنا هذه المساله عندما اقر قانون السماح
للمراه في الانتخاب والترشح
وفرض الاسلاميون تعديلا على هذا القانون
بان يكون هذا الحق في الانتخاب والترشح
وفق اللباس الشرعي اذكروا وقتها كتبنا عده
مقالات ما هو مفهوم اللباس الشرعي ماذا
تريدون من المراه هل المراه التي وضعت
غطاء على راسها واظهرت جميع مفاتنها
متحجبه هل المراه التي اظهرت جزء من شعرها
او جزءا من يدها او جزءا من ساقها متحجبه
بمجرد انها وضعت شيئا على راسها المساله
غير قابله للتطبيق ولا يحتاج المجتمع الى
مثل هذه
مثل هذه اللجان او هذه المناداه بلا اي
شكل انه لا يحتاج ويبقى السؤال سيد محمد
ربما الى اي مدى يمكن ان تؤدي هذه الوثيقه
الى مزيد من الانقسامات او حتى تسبب
انقسامات جديده في الداخل السياسي الكويتي
شكرا جزيلا لك من الكويت المحلل السياسي
محمد السبتي
رجعت الرابعه مستمره وتتابعون فيها
القطاع غير النفطي يقود نمو الاقتصاد
السعودي في الربع الاول من العام الجاري
احييكم من جديد في السعوديه حقق الاقتصاد
نموا بنسبه 3.8 خلال الربع الاول من العام
الجاري مقارنه مع الربع المماثل في العام
الماضي مدفوعا بنمو الانشطه غير النفطيه
وقد نمت الانشطه غير النفطيه بنسبه 5.4
على اساس سنوي و1% على اساس رباعي وكان
صندوق النقد الدولي قد توقع بالامس ان
يبقى زخم النمو غير النفطي في السعوديه
قويا خلال العام الجاري وان يسجل نموا
بنسبه 5% في المتوسط بالنصف الاول من 20
23 اما الناتج المحلي النفطي فقد نمى
بنسبه 1.4% على اساس سنويا لكنه تراجع
4.7% على اساس رباعي
معنى هنا في الاستوديو الدكتور محمد مكني
استاذ الماء الماليه والاستثمار في جامعه
الامام اهلا بك معنا دكتور في نشره
الرابعه حياك الله دكتور هذا الارتفاع في
النمو غير النفطي في السعوديه الى ماذا
يشير طبعا هذا اللي عملت عليه السعوديه
خلال الفتره السابقه الحقيقه بحيث انه
يكون عندنا نقلل الاعتماد على الانشطه
النفطيه واليوم احنا الحمد لله بنلمس
الارتفاعات المتتاليه
5.4% على اساس سنوات مقارنه بنفس الفتره
من عام 23 اعتقد انه رقم كبير جدا ايضا
المشاورات الماده الرابعه كان متوقع ويوم
امس في تقريرهم الصادر انه ينتهي هذا
العام بمتوسط ارتفاع يتجاوز الخمسه بالمئه
واحنا بنعرف انه في نهايه عام 22 الانشطه
غير النفطيه حققت حوالي 4.8% معناته احنا
الحمد لله قاعدين نتوسع في مساله القطاع
غير النفطي دعم القطاع الخاص اتمام
المشروعات الكبرى عندنا حتى انه هي تكون
كبير جدا ان شاء الله للميزانيه السعوديه
بعيد عن الاثار اللي يمكن تتحقق او تسير
في حاله انه كان عندنا اي مشاكل في القطع
النفطي احنا يمكن لاحظنا اليوم يمكن ان
المتتبع للارقام من الربع الثاني من عام
2021 كان عندنا ارتفاع في الانشطه النفطيه
والانشطه غير النفطيه بينما هذا الربع
الحقيقي على اساس موسمي وجدنا انه اصبح
هناك تراجع بواحد فاصله اربعه بالمئه بسبب
انه هناك تراجع في الانشطه النفطيه فلازال
هناك اثر الحقيقه على مستوى ربعي للانشطه
النفطيه تراجعت بحوالي 4.7% وطبعا هذا
طبعا ما في شك انه هو بسبب يعني تراجع
الاسعار في الفتره الحاليه ايضا الانتاج
انتاج النفط يعني التخفيضات الطبيعيه التي
حصلت في مجموعه اوبيك بلس برضو تراجعته
وبالتالي ادت الى انه يتراجع النشاط
النفطي لكن بشكل عام اعتقد انه الارقام
مبشره بالخير خصوصا فيما يخص الانشطه غير
النفطيه لو استكملنا على نفس النهجه في
الربع الثاني والربع الثالث حتى الربع
الرابع انا اعتقد انه احنا فعلا حنتجاوز
خمسه او نص بالمئه ربما فيما يخص الانشطه
غير النفط طيب دكتور يعني تراجع الانشطه
النفطيه ربما هذا من احد اسباب ارتفاع نمو
نمو القطاع الغير النفطي ولكن ما الاسباب
الاخرى كمان اللي ادت الى ارتفاع النمو في
القطاع غير الضفد كذلك الدعم الدعم
الحكومي موجود الحقيقه يعني التوسع كبير
اليوم الانفاق الحكومي على المشروعات كنا
في الاسبوع الماضي اسمه سيدي ولي العهد
اطلق المناطق الاقتصاديه الاربعه احنا
شفنا كيف التركيز على الانشطه غير النفطيه
وخصوصا ما يخص
خلينا نقول الانشطه الواحده مثل صناعه
السفن صناعه السيارات وغيرها اطلقنا ثلاثه
استراتيجيات مهمه بتدعم القطاع غير النفطي
عندنا الاستراتيجيه النقل والخدمات
اللوجستيه الاستراتيجيه الاستثمار الوطني
استراتيجيه الصناعه كل هذه الاستراتيجيات
الحقيقه لو تلاحظ يعني من ضمن بنود هذا
الاستراتيجيات هي دائما القطاع الخاص
تمكين القطاع الغير النفطي وبالتالي هذا
كله ما في شك انعكاس على انه لنشاهد هذا
الارقام الكبيره في في يعني الانشطه غير
النفطيه يعني دكتور بالنسبه للتوقعات
الاربعه
اعتقد انه لو استمرينا ان شاء الله تعالى
بنفس النهج وهذا هو يعني المامول انه
الانفاق اليوم الحكومي عندنا كبير وما
اصبح الحقيقه معلق بمقدار العوائد من
الانشطه النفطيه فبالتالي اكيد انه احنا
حنشوف ارقام ويمكن ذكروا وزير الماليه في
في مؤتمر الماليه الاخير في شهر مارس ذكر
انه متوقع انه تجاوز الخمسه بالمئه يعني
نموا في الانشطه غير النفطيه بسبب الدعم
الحكومي الكبير واضح شكرا جزيلا لك
الدكتور استاذ الماليه والاستثمار في
جامعه الامام دكتور محمد مكني
[موسيقى]
نفى فيصل العتيبي ابن الشاعر السعودي
الشهير خلف بن هذال عبر حسابه الرسمي على
منصه تويتر نفى الاخبار المتداوله عن وفاه
والده جمله وتفصيلا مؤكدا ان والده بخير
ويذكر ان الشاعر خلف بن هذال يعد احد اشهر
الشعراء على المستوى الخليجي وشارك عبر
سنوات طويله بقصائده الوطنيه من خلال
مهرجان الجنادريه
ينضم الينا من الرياض فيصل بن الشاعر خلف
بن هذال اهلا بك معنا سيد فيصل بدايه طمنا
على صحه الوالد
يا هلا ومرحبا بقناه العربيه وبرنامج
الرابع وفيك يا اختي الوالد يبشرك بخير
ولله الحمد الله يعيش حياه الخاصه بيني
ابنائه وبنات واحفاده والله يطول في عمره
ويحفظه ويخليه لنا ولا يرينا فيه مكروه
[موسيقى]
وحنا متعودين على الاشاعات من قبل من عشر
سنوات ومن تواصل الاجتماعي
الخبر البارح جاء متاخر شوي لو انه بدري
لفيناه بدري ولا انتشر اكثر من كذا لكن
جاء من بعد الساعه 1:30 واكثر اللي سلموه
وانا مفجوعين من الخبر
اكيد
ولكن حينما يعني تم نفي خبر وفاته من غير
شر استاذ فيصل يعني ربما كان هناك سعاده
غمرت ايضا المشاركين في مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي بخبر صحته وانه بخير يعني
اي والله الحمد لله الحمد لله السعاده
غمرتهم لكن اللي كلمونا مفجوعين اكثر من
السعيدين اعوذ بالله
بسرعه والله تنتشر بسرعه نعم نعم
قناه العربيه الساحره في نشرها بعد والان
نحن نستضيفك لكي نطمئن الجميع وجميع محبي
الشاعر بانه بالخير وبصحه وعافيه الله
يديمها عليها بالصحه استاذ فيصل انا ودي
اسالك عن اي مشاركات شعبيه
قبل ما اقاطعك انا تمنيت ان قناه العربيه
تتصل فينا وتتاكد من الخبر مثل ما اتصلتوا
الان تبغى تطمنون عليه
دائما يعني حريصين جدا على ذلك ولذلك
نستضيفك معنا اليوم ويسعدنا استضافتك سيد
فيصل اسمح لي ان اسالك عن اي مشاركات
قادمه شعريه للوالد ربما نترقبها في
المستقبل القريب
والله الوالد
شارك 50 سنه الحمد لله وقصائد تت
جدد يوم بعد يوم
الاعياد المناسبه الوطنيه والحمد لله
متواجد واتوقع جديد
لم نعتذر الشعر من عشر سنوات
والان يعني
شكرا لوجودك معنا السيد فيصل ويعني ونحن
سعيدين بخبر صحه والدك ونتمنى له دوام
الصحه والعافيه بكل تاكيد من الرياض فيصل
ابن الشاعر خلف شكرا جزيلا لك مجددا
اما القرى ام تبر بجنينها
الفرح والعز في نون عينها حلت وسلت كل من
حل حولها بالعيد وفود الفزائرينها
والدار بحماك تم منها وتامنها
لوام
القايده
تمث ارواحنا في سبيل الله نعربنها
السلام لسى هالقلب عن ذكر الاله
ربنا اللي نزل اقرا وعلم بالقلم
جلساني في جلاله تبارك في علاه منفرد
بالغيب
رابعه مستمره وفيها
العربيه تلتقي اصغر نحاله بالقطيف شرقي
السعوديه هوايه تحولت الى مشروع ينتج 800
كيلو جرام من العسل
احييكم من جديد انهى مركز الملك سلمان
للاغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه برامج اعاده
تاهيل 26 طفلا مجندا من عده محافظات يمنيه
ضمن مشروع اعاده تاهيل الاطفال الذين
جندتهم الميليشيات الحوثيه حيث تلقى
الاطفال من خلال المشروع تاهيل مكثف من
الدعم النفسي والاجتماعي والرياضي الثقافي
والترفيهي من خلال تنفيذ العديد من
الانشطه لمده ثلاثه اشهر يذكر ان المشروع
يستهدف اعاده تاهيل 175 طفلا مجندا او
مشاركا في مارب
وسيئون خلال العام الجاري
اعلن الامن العام عبر حسابه الرسمي على
تويتر ان شرطه تبوك قبضت على ثلاثه
مواطنين لاتخاذهم منزلا شعبيا مهجورا وكرا
لاخفاء وترويج ماده فيتامين وماده الحشيش
المخدر بالاضافه الى اقتنائهم اسلحه ناريه
وكاميرات مراقبه حيث تم اتخاذ الاجراءات
النظاميه بحقهم واحالتهم الى الجهات
المختصه
[موسيقى]
اعلنت وزاره الصحه السعوديه عن تدشين اكبر
المختبرات الطبيه المتخصصه في السعوديه
بشراكه استراتيجيه سعوديه صينيه حيث ستعمل
على توفير حلول متكامله باستخدام احدث
التقنيات التشخيصيه بهدف توطين الاختبارات
الجنينيه المتخصصه وتقديم الفحوصات
الروتينيه هذا ويعد برنامج التحول الصحي
في السعوديه احد الركائز الاساسيه التي
تقوم عليها البلاد لاعاده هيكله القطاع
الصحي ليكون نظاما صحيا شاملا وفعالا
ومتكاملا يقوم على صحه الفرد والمجتمع
تعد فاطمه الميلاد اصغر نحاله في محافظه
القطيف شرقي السعوديه ورثت شغفها في تربيه
النحل من والدها الذي عمل مربيا للنحل
فاطمه نجحت في تحويل هو هوايتها الى مشروع
ناجح ينتج نحو 800 كلغ سنويا من العسل
والذي يستهدف الاسواق المحليه والخليجيه
المزيد مع مراسلنا على اللعبه
منذ صغرها ارتبطت بالنحل بدافع الترفيه
والاستكشاف امتلكت اول خليه في منحل
والدها وهي في عمر الخامسه عشره فاطمه
الميلاد اصغرون حاله في محافظه القطيف شرق
السعوديه والتي تمتلك اليوم ما يصل الى
200 خليه من النحل
بدايه في تربيه النحل كانت مرحله استكشاف
مع الوالد وحب الاطلاع على عالم النحل
بعدها حاولت تنفرد بخليه واحده الخليه
الواحده هذه تمكنت من ادارتها بشكل كامل
بعد ما تمكنت من ادارتها بشكل كامل استشرت
الوالد في امتلاك من حل صغير متنقل وانفرت
بخمسين خليه وخمسين خليه هذي ما شاء الله
خلال خمس سنوات من عمري 15 سنه لحد
العشرين سنه انفرت ب 200 خليه
[موسيقى]
منذ الثامنه صباحا تبداون حاله فاطمه
يومها في متابعه خلايا النحل والتاكد من
سلامتها ونظافه المياه علاقتها مع النحل
اكسبتها مزيدا من الصبر والدقه بشكل يومي
لازم اتاكد ان الخلايا تكون سليمه
الاطارات موضوعه بشكل سليم اتاكد من نظافه
الماي اتاكد من كل شيء كل شيء سليم تقريبا
اتواجد في المنحه من ثمان الصباح لحد 4:00
العصر طوال انا فتره موجوده في القطيف لما
اكون برا القطيفه اتواصل مع الوالد بشكل
يوم انه يحضر ويتاكد لي من سلامه الخلايا
نجحت فاطمه في تحويل شغفها في تربيه النحل
الى مشروع تجاري ينتج ما بين 600 الى 800
كيلو سنويا من عسل السدر وزهور الربيعي
والمنجروف
وتستهدف منتجاتها السوق المحلي والخليجي
بالنسبه للانتاج السنوي ينتج سنويا حوالي
من 600 الى 800 كيلو من ثلاثه انواع من
الاعسار عسل السدر وعسل زهور الربيع وعسل
المانجروف والحمد لله الانتاج ما يقتصر
على السوق المحلي فقط بل حتى دول الخليج
يصدر لهم وايضا تركيا وان شاء الله باقي
الدول نتوسع في هذا المجال من القطيف علي
اللقبي العربيه
في السعوديه يدخل حي قرطبه خامس الاحياء
السكنيه المشموله في برنامج الرياضه
الخضراء ضمن مشروع تشجير الاحياء الذي
يستهدف تشجير وتطوير البنيه التحتيه
للتشجير والري في اكثر من 120 حي في
الرياض وسيطفي المشروع على الحي مساحه
خضراء من خلال زراعه 92 الف شجره وشجيره
واربعه وثلاثين حديقه اضافه الى تشجير 44
كيلومترا من الشوارع والممرات
حذرت الارصاد الجويه العمانيه من ارتياد
بحر العرب وممارسه اي نشاط بحري عليه وذلك
غداه تشكل الاعصار المداري ببرجو ببر جوي
واشارت الارصاد العمانيه الى ان امواج
البحر سيصل ارتفاعها من ثلاثه الى سته
امتار على السواحل بدءا من غدا الجمعه
مضيفه ان الحاله قد تستمر الى ثلاثه ايام
من جهته اعلن المركز الوطني للارصاد في
السعوديه ان الحاله المداريه في بحر العرب
لا يوجد لها اي تاثير مباشر على اجواء
السعوديه خلال الثلاثه ايام القادمه
واوضحت ان الحاله المداريه للاعصار تصنف
من الدرجه الاولى حيث يبعد مركز الاعصار
من السواحل 1050 كم
للاعاصير خمسه درجات الدرجه الخامسه تكون
سرعه دوران الرياح اكثر من 225 كيلومتر في
الساعه وهي الدرجه المدمره التفاصيل في
تقويم مع خالد ازعاج
[موسيقى]
الريح التي تهب بشده وترتفع الى عنان
السماء مثل العمود تسمى عند اهل اللغه
العربيه بل اعصار والعامه يسمونه بالعاصوف
والاعصار عند اهل الارصاد هي منطقه ضغط
منخفضه تجلب الرياح الى مركزها والاعصار
يمر بمراحل عده قبل تشكله يبدا منخفض جوي
بين قوسين سحب فاذا زادت حركته تحول عاصفه
مداريه لسرعه دورانه ولانه يتشكل في
المناطق المداريه وهي المناطق الواقعه بين
مدار السرطان الى مدار الجدي فاذا زادت
حركه دورانه عمي 118 كيلو متر بس ساعه
تحول الى اعصار يا رب سلط على الاحزان
عاصفه من المسرات لا تبقي ولا تذروا وابعث
الينا من التفريج مكرومه وامن على من غزاه
الهم
والكدر
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
والاعاصير خمس درجات تصنف على حسب سرعه
دورانيه حول المركز بالكيلومتر بساعه
الدرجه الاولى سرعته من 119 الى 153 وهو
ضعيف الدرجه الثانيه من 154 الى 177 وهو
متوسط الدرجه الثالثه سرعته من 178 الى
208 وهو قوي الدرجه الرابعه من ننتقل
للمشاهدين مباشره الى المؤتمر الصحفي على
هامش الاجتماع الوزاري للتحالف الدولي
لمحاربه داعش في الرياض نستمع كما ودنا
نرحب ايضا في هذا المكان بانضمام جمهوريه
توغو للتحالف ليصبح ضد الدول الاعضاء في
86 دوله ومنظمه وباعتباره اكبر تحالف دولي
لمواجهه هذا التنظيم الارهابي
خلال الاجتماعاتنا اليوم ناقشنا سبل اعاده
استقرار في الاراضي المحرره من تنظيم داعش
في سوريا والعراق باعتبارها من ضمن قائمات
لدى التحالف واكدنا على اهميه استمرار
الجهود في هذا الاطار كما اكد المشاركون
على الالتزامهم واستمرارهم في الحد من
مصادر التمويل الارهاب والوسائل نشر
والترويج كما تجد الاشاره هنا
المملكه لمجموعه مكافحه التمويل داعش
وجهودها الكبيره في اطار تنسيق عمل كافه
الدول في التحالف للتصدي لتمويل هذا
التنظيم كما بحثنا الاجراءات التي يمكن
اتباعها لمجابهه الارهاب والميليات
المسلحه في غرب افريقيا ودول الساحل ووسط
وجنوب افريقيا والتي بدورها تزعزع الامن
والاستقرار في المنطقه وان المملكه ستشارك
في رئاسه مجموعه الكريس خاصه بافريقيا
ايمانا من التحالف
باهميه التركيز على هذا التحدي نظرا لما
يش
يعني مصدر للتهديد ليس فقط لدول الساحل
لكن لدول المنطقه اجمع والعالم وهنا اود
ان يؤثني على هذا التركيز المستجد على
التحدي التي تواجه القاره الافريقيه من
الارهاب واستشعارنا جميعا في المجتمع
الدولي بمسؤولياتنا اتجاه التعاون
والتنسيق لمجابهه هذا التحدي كما اود ان
اؤكد على اهميه مجرى واجهه التنظيمات
الارهابيه في افغانستان لضمان ان لا تصبح
مجددا ملاذا امنا لهذه التنظيمات
وكذلك مهم ان نؤكد مره اخرى على ضروره
التزام المجتمع الدولي واطلاعي بادواره في
مواجهه التحديات المشتركه ومن ابرز
الارهاب والعمل على توفير البيئه الملائمه
بعوده النازحين في سوريا والعراق واجراء
الاصلاحات القضائيه لمحاسبه الارهابيين
واهميه اطلاع الدول الغنيه بمسؤولياتها
اتجاه عوده مواطنيها من مناطق النزاع
وحمايه الاجيال القادمه من اضرار هذه
الافه
وتبعاتها والحقيقه من المؤسف ان لازال
هناك عدد من الدول الغنيه الدول المتقدمه
التي ترفض استعاده مواطنيها
وترمي بهذا العبء على دول المتاثره الاكثر
تاثرا بالارهاب المملكه تقوم بدورها
وتستعد كافه مواطنيها من مواقع الصراع
ونحن مستعدون ان نساعد من يحتاج فيما
يتعلق باعاده التحيير والانخراط المجتمع
لكن الدول كافه عليها مسؤوليه تحمل
ما قام به مواطنوها وان يستعيدونهم
ويرفعون هذا العب عن الدول المتاثره كما
او في هذا المناسبه نؤكد على متانه
العلاقه السعوديه الامريكيه التاريخيه
وما ناقشته مع صديقي توني البارحه في
لقائنا ثنائي وكما ايضا تم مناقشته في
لقاء سيدي العهد
في التشاور في القضايا ذات الاهتمام الشرك
الى تعزيز الامن واستقرار الاقليميه
والدولي واستعرضنا ملفات كثيره في المنطقه
كذلك اطر التعاون بين بلدينا وهناك مجال
واسع لهذا التعاون وسنستمر في بحث سبل
دعم هذا التعاون لما في مصلحه بلدينا
واود ختامنا اود ان نشير وهذه نقطه مهمه
الحقيقه ان المشاركون اكدوا على ان التطرف
والارهاب في كافه اشكاله ومظاهره يجب ان
لا يرتبط باي دين او جنسيه او مجموعه
عرقيه ولا يكون عذرا
لاتخاذ اي اجراءات او اي تفرقه او اي
عنصريه تجاه اي مجموعه عرقيه
وان لا يكون المسلمون عرضه لمضايقات مجرد
لان بعض الفئات ربما
انتهجت نهجا مخالفا وهذا ينطبق على جميع
العرقيات شكرا واعطي الكلمه للسيد توني
وزير الخارجيه فيصل اشكركم اشكركم على
ضيافتكم
وعلى جمع الشركائنا الاقليميه والدوريين
هنا في الرياض عندما سافر رئيس الى جده في
الصيف الماضي اكد على اهميه الشرق الاوسط
من اجل مصالح امريكا على المدى البعيد
ونحن ملتزمون بالاستمرار وتعزيز شركاتنا
في المنطقه معا نستطيع ان نحقق التقدم
لكافه شعوبنا ليس فقط لمعالجه التحديات
والزمات الحاليه
لصياغه رؤيا حاسمه لمستقبلنا المشترك عبر
الماضيه لقد حققنا هذا التقدم عبر عده
جبهات من خلال العامه وشركائنا السعوديين
وبجلس التعاون الخليجي والعمل اليوم مع
التحالف الدولي له هزيمه ايداع الشعب
الخارجيه لقد انهيت اجتماعا بناء مع هذا
التحالف الدولي الولايات المتحده ممتنه
لقياده المملكه العربيه السعوديه ليس فقط
في استضافه هذا الاجتماع بل لاسهاماتها
المستمره
في كل يوم تحقيق هذه المهمه مع تحالفنا
يستعيد الاراضي اذا كانت يسيطر عليها داعش
وتكبدهم خساره فادحه في قيادتها فتبقى
داعش تمثل تهديد المستمر اجتماع الوزاري
ركز على عده مجالات ضروريه
من ضمنها تحقيق الاستقرار في المناطق
المحرره من داعش لكي لا تستغل الجماعه
الامن الضعيف او الظروف الانسانيه
والاقتصاديه
التي تترك
السكات كما اعتقد ياسين وكما سمعتم من
وزير الخارجيه
اعاده
الارهابيين الاجانب الى اوطانهم
نحن نعمل ايضا مع التهديدات الناشئه من
ضمنها جهودي داعش في شبهه الصحارى
الافريقيه وداعش خرسان اعضاء الاتحاد 86
مركزين بشكل اكبر لاكمالي هذه المهمه
للتخلص من داعش المملكه العربيه
السعوديه والولايات المتحده وشركاتنا
ومستعل الخليجي نعمل عن قرب لمعالجه عده
تحديات اخرى في المنطقه مثلها اليمن عندما
تولى رئيس بايدن الاداره كانت الحرب
مستعره وكانت تواجه واوضع اسوا اوضاع
انسانيه في العالم والان نعمل بشكل مكثر
مع السعوديه وشركاء اخرين
تحقيق هذا
الاستقرار في القتال الذي ما دام على 14
شهر اليوم في سنه ايضا للقاء رئيس اليمن
لمناقشه المسار المستقبلي هدفنا واهدافنا
دائم
وعمليه يمنيه شامله بواسطه الامم المتحده
وطالب والعداله والمساءله
والختام تقود الى حل سياسي
بالخلافات في اليمن مفضل سوف يستمر بالعمل
مع الاطراف
في الايام الاسابيع المقبل لحل المشاكل
العالقه في وجه السلام الدائم الولايات
المتحده والسعوديه لجانب الخليجي تركز
وايضا على نشاطات ايران مزعزع المنطقه من
ضمنها دعمها على الرحابي والمليشيات او
تلائها على السفن البحريه والتصعيد النووي
هناك متحده تستمر
بايمانها بين دبلوماسيه الى جانب ضغوط
الاقتصاديه ورد او التعاون الدفاع يه
القوي هي السبيل الامثل لمعالجه ومواجهه
هذه النشاطات الخطره دعم جهود السعوديه
حول ازمه السودان
وسعوديه تقود حملات الدبلوماسيه لدفع
الجانبين للالتزام بوقف اطلاق النار
وللسماحين بوصول لمساعدات الانسانيه الى
الشعب السودانيين سوف نستمر بالعمل تجاه
تحقيق وقت اطلق نار دائم
وتشكيله قياده مدنيه انتقاليه
هذا الاتفاق انهى الازمه المروعه
للمسائله الى جانب التسويه او امريكا
تستمر بتشاركه
السعوديه او الخليج علاقاتنا تمتد بعيدا
عن مجرد هذه التحديات فهي ضروريه جدا
لتوسيعيه الفرص والدفعي التقدم لشعبنا
ولشعوب العالم
وعبر الشركات التحتيه العالميه
والاستثمارات امريكا والسعوديه تعملان
معانة التحتيه ذات الجوده العاليه
لمصلحه
المتوسط وحتى بتجه رقميه من خلال
التكنولوجيا الاتصالات
مثل الشبكات السحابيه الامنه وقليله
التكلفه نحن كافح ازمه المناخ ونسرع
الانتقال الى طاقه نظيف في المنطقه عبر
الشركات الثنائيه
في الصيف الماضي والذي يفك عنه طاقه
الهيدروجين النظيف والطاقه الشمسيه وغيرها
جانب اساسي من استراتيجيتنا
لتحق المنطقه المستقره او حواء تخفيفي الى
توترات الخليج مترابطه الان اكثر من اي
وقت سبق كمنطقه وكذلك مع الدول الاخرى في
الشرق الاوسط من ضمنها اسرائيل امريكا
ستستمر بلعب دور اساسي في تعزيز وتوسيع
عمليه التطبيع كما قال الرئيس بايدن في
جده الحقوق العالميه والحريات والحمايه
التي توفرها هي اولويه اساسيه لامريكا
وشراكه سعودي الامريكيه تتعمق خلال
تطور عمله حقوق الانسان لهذا اتخذنا خطوات
تاريخيه لتعزيز دور المراه في مكان العمل
والتسامح بين الزيادات المعتقدات ضمن
اجنده هذه الدوله طموحه
وهذه نقطه اوضحتها بشكل جيد في اجتماعاتنا
هذا الاسبوع في الاسبوع الماضي امريكا
رواد الفضاء الامريكيين والسعوديين عادل
الارض بعد قضاء عشره ايام معا في محطه
الفضاء الدوليه وتلك المهمه شملت ريحانه
ناوي اول اراده فضائل عربيه تزور الفضاء
وفي رساله الاولى من الفضاء ريحانه توقعت
بان المستقبل مشرق ولذلك اقول لنجعله
مشرقا معا شكرا
والان مع صله الزملاء من وسائل الاعلام
قناه العربيه
سمو وزير الخارجيه السعودي الامير فيصل بن
فرحان
هل التهديدات اليوم التي يشكلها تنظيم
داعش في بعض دول افريقيا وما دفع الاعلان
بانضمام السعوديه لرئاسه مجموعه التركيز
المعنيه بالشام الافريقي لمواجهه التنظيم
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي
اجتماعات مع ولي عهد السعوديه الامير محمد
بن سلمان لساعات وايضا اوضحت او كما وصفت
انه اجتمعت معه لساعات وناقشت معهم ملفات
او ملفات كثيره هل لنا ان نعرف بالتفصيل
عن هذه الملفات وايضا الملفات التي يرغ
بها ولي العهد السعودي مع امريكا شكرا لك
شكرا هاني
منظمه المملكه لرئاسه المجموعه الخاصه
بافريقيا ايمانا من
بمسؤولياتنا تجاه الشراكه العميقه التي
تملك المملكه العربيه السعوديه مع القاره
الافريقيه ق ننظر لها
كمصدر مهم
للتعاون والتنسيق والدول الافريقيه كلها
بالمجمل لها علاقه قويه بالمملكه العربيه
السعوديه ونحن مساهمون اساسيون في التنميه
في تلك الدول
ونستشعر بالمسؤولياتنا تجاه الحفاظ على ما
حصل من تقدم في هذه الدول والتعاون معها
والتنسيق فيما يخص مجابهه هذا التعديد
الذي يهدد امن واستقرار القاره كافه
وينعكس حقيقه ايضا على امن واستقرار
المملكه العربيه السعوديه بحكم الجوار
والمسؤوليه مشتركه لمواجهه هذا التحدي
بالذات ان كثير من الدول الافريقيه ينقصها
القدرات التقنيه والمعرفه في هذا المجال
وكما واجهنا داعش في العراق وسوريا كمجتمع
دولي المسؤوليه ايضا ان نواجه التنظيمات
الارهابيه في القاره الافريقيه كمجتمع
دولي وبالتنسيق والتعاون
وسنعمل على ذلك وسندعم كل جهود الدوليه في
هذا الاطار
الا نكرر ما ذكره مع الوزير الخارجيه ومره
اخرى
وكتذكار فان هذا التحالف
الدوله ومنظمه وهو اكبر تحالف في العالم
وقد حقق تقدم نجاحا كبيرا جدا مدعم واربعه
عشر في استعاده الاراضي التي سيطر عليها
داعش في العراق وسوريا
والتخلص من القيادات العليا
وتقليلي التهديد ولكن التهديد مستمر
والى جانب ذلك فهو
ينتقل الى مناطق اخرى وبشكل خاص الى مناطق
من افريقيا وهذا كان علينا ان نركز اليوم
وفي تحالفنا على بعض التحديات التي
يواجهها الشركائنا في افريقيا وبشكل خاصتي
الساحل وغرب افريقيا
فالامر بتكره التعالف هو انه يتكيف ومرن
وحتى مع سمارت تركيزنا العراقي وسوريا
لضماني
عدم اعاده بروز تهديد 11
يجب ان نضمن تركيزنا على مناطق اخرى قد
يكون فيه اكثر نشاطا وكما ذكرنا الان
افريقيا ولهذا السبب تركيز هذا التحالف
منصب على افريقيا بالشراكه الكامله مع
الدول الافريقيه
اخر شيء اود ان اذكره وما هو جدير بالذكر
من نقاشاتنا اليوم وكل العمل الذي قمنا به
هو
ضروره المقاربه المكثفه الامن
الضروري ولكن
هناك تحديات كيف نواجهها من داعش وسمعنا
من شركائنا فنظرات التعامل مع
المخاوفه واحتياجاتي المجتمعات المهمشه
وتوفير الفرص الاقتصاديه وضمان
وجود الحوكمه الجيده
والمقاربه السياسيه شفافه كل هذه الاشياء
الضروره لتحقيق نجاح ضد داعش ومنعها من
التجنيد
والتوسعه في مناطق اخرى
السؤال الثاني
شكرا
معالي وزير الخارجيه صاحب السموم
السعوديه للحصول على الدعم لتطوير برامجها
النووي المدني بمقابله تطبيق علاقاتها مع
اسرائيل وهل تقولون بان هذا الشرط غير
قابل للتفاوض من اجل التطبيع والسؤال اخر
المملكه العربيه السعوديه قامت بالعديد من
الاصلاحات ان الجماعات حقوق الانسان افادت
عن عمليه
حول هذه المساله الوزير بلانكن ناقشت مع
والي العهد السعودي مثلا التطبيع ما هو
التقدم الذي حصل ومدى امكانيه الوصول الى
هذا الاتفاق انه ربما يسرب بعين عمليه
تسريع التسلح مع ايران وحلب هل تلقيتهم اي
ضمانات من ولي العهد اتجاه اطلاق المساجين
السياسيين
شكرا جزيلا فيما يخص التعاون النووي ليس
سرا نحن نطور برنامجنا نوويه المدني
ونفضل ان
تكون امريكا متقدمه لتطوير هذا البرنامج
الدول الاخرى تتقدم مع سعينه هذا البرنامج
افضل تكنولوجيا في العالم وهذا سيتطلب
اتفاق معين لدينا خلافات فرعي ونحن نعمل
على جاد اليه للعمل معا على تكنولوجيا
المدنيه والاسعار للمضي قدما في هذا
البرنامج اما التطبيع وكما قلتم مسبقا
وواضح نحن نؤمن بان التطبيع يصب في مصلحه
المنطقه
وسوف يقدم فوائد كبيره للجميع ولكن من دون
ايجاد السبيله للسلام لشعب الفلسطيني بدون
معالجه هذا التحدي فان اي تطبيق
سيكون له فوائد محدوده وبالتالي علينا
الاستم التركيز على ايجاد السبيل اتجاهها
حلت دولتين
والمساره تجاه منحى الفلسطينيين الكرامه
والعداله
وامريكا لديها وجهه نظر مشابهه من المهم
جدا ان نستمر على هذه الجهود سالتي عن
حقوق الانسان والاصلاحات
ومن المعروف اننا قمنا او حققنا تقدمه
كبيره في الاصلاحات المملكه وما نقوم هنا
كله وفقا لتقييمنا فيما يصب في مصلحه
بلادنا وهم مدفوع باحتياجات ورغبات الشعب
السعودي انتم عشتم بعض الايام هنا واتمنى
ان تكونوا قد شاهدتم التغيرات الكبيره
التي حصلت في المملكه ولكن نحن دائما
نفتحون لخوض الحوار مع اصدقائنا ولكننا
نستجيب للضغوط عندما نقوم باي شيء نحن
نقوم بذلك حسب مصالحنا ولا اعتقد
بان اي شخص يؤمن بان الضغط مفيد
وبالتالي فهذا ليس بالشي ء
حتى سنه الاولويه هي تحقيق الاهداف التي
وضعناها لبلادنا نحن نركز بشكل كبير على
بناء المسارات تجاه
الازدهار المستدام للشعب السعودي وانا
احسكم انتم وكل لديه اي فضول
لقضاء بعض الوقت في المملكه والتفاعل مع
الشعب السعودي واحكموا بانفسكم
فيما يخص التطبيع اولا وكما تعرفون نحن
ندعم بالكامل اندماج اسرائيل في الشرق
الاوسط
منذ اليوم الاول
ونحن نعمل من اجل تعذيب بعض العلاقات
القائمه اصلا وكذلك لتوسيعها مع دول اخرى
وهذا يشمل المملكه العربيه السعوديه اعتقد
ان هذه السكون خطوه هامه جدا للمستقبل
وبلا شك ستكون اولويه وهي بالفعل اولويه
بالنسبه لنا الاندماج جيد للمنطقه باكملها
وسوف نستمر لتحقيق ذلك ناقشنا ذلك هنا
وسوف نستمر
بالعمل عليها وتحقيقها في الايام
والاسابيع والاشهر المقبله اما فيما يخص
المواطنين الامريكيين وحقوق الانسان بشكل
عام اسمحوا لي انا اقول اولا
حقوق الانسان دائما على جده الولايات
المتحده
هذه المساله خلال الماضيه كما اوضحنا بان
التقدم في حقوق الانسان يقوي علاقتنا
وسوف ان استمر بالتحدث عن ذلك بشكل عام
وخاصه عن حقوق الانسان
هنالك شيء اخر في غايه الاهميه وقد ذكره
مع الوزير الخارجيه
المملكه العربيه السعوديه انطلقت في جهود
جباره وتاريخيه لتحديث
اقتصادها
ومجتمعها
وجزء من ذلك
سيجذب افضل المواهب بكافه انحاء العالميه
السعوديه لزيارتها والسعي الى تعلمي هنا
والاستثمار
والمشاركه والعمل الى جانب السعوديين
ومن وجهه نظرنا رؤيه 2030 كما سمى هذه
المبادره
ستحقق نجاحا اكبر بكثير
اذا ما كانت السعوديه اكثر مكانا جذابا
لكف سكان العالم المجيئي اليها وبالتالي
اعتقده بانها حسب وصفها ومن مصلحه العربيه
السعوديه ان تستمر
بالسعي لهذه هذا التحديث وتوسيع حقوق
الانسان اما فيما خصوص المواطنين
الامريكيين كما تعرفون كما ذكرت مرارا ان
رفعها وان المواطنه الامريكي في كل مكان
حول العالم هو اولويتي القصوى ومسؤوليه
وهذا هو التركيز وزاره الخارجيه ايضا نحن
مستمرون
بالعمليه نيابه عن الافراد قدر الامكان
وتسنت لي الفرصه
لطرح بعض المسائل ولن اخوض في المزيد من
التفاصيل
السلام عليكم محمد المحمود من قناه سكاي
نيوز عربيه سؤالي الاول موجه لسمو الامير
في الملف السوداني بعد الجهود السعوديه
الامريكيه المشتركه
والحث على عقد هذه الاتفاقيات التي تمت في
جده ما القادم من الجهود الدبلوماسيه
خصوصا مع استمرار الاشتباكات داخل الاراضي
السودانيه السؤال الاخر لمعالي الوزير
بلنكن قلتم في كلمتكم صباحات اليوم باننا
لا نريد ان تصبح افغانستان امنا
للارهابيين كيف يمكن ان نوفق بين هذا
الكلام وبين الانسحاب الامريكي من
افغانستان الذي فتح المجال امام التنظيمات
الارهابيه والاعمال الارهابيه اخرها صباح
هذا اليوم تفجير في مسجد في افغانستان نتج
عنه 18 وفاه و33 اصابه شكرا لكم شكرا
بالنسبه للسودان اولا اود ان اعبر عن خالص
شكري للتعامل الكبير الذي حظينا به من
الجانب الامريكي في المحادثات التي
وصلت في جده للمحاوله
للتعامل مع الوضع الانساني الحرج نتيجه
لما حصل من اقتتال داخل السودان
حققنا بعض النجاح لم يكن نجاحا كاملا لان
الاطراف لم يلتزموا التزاما كاملا ونستمر
في العمل لبحث السبل لرفع المعاناه عن
الشعب السوداني عن طريق الوصول الى
تفاهمات معينه مع الاطراف هناك بوادر
ايجابيه حتى اليوم في المحادثات قد نصل
الى هدنه اخرى مع اليات مراقبه اكثر تشددا
تساعدنا في تحديد مواطن
الخلل او المخالفه ان حصل ذلك وان التزم
الاطراف سيكون ذلك بصيص عمل جديد لاخواننا
في السودان وهنا اوجه كلامي مره اخرى الى
الاشقاء في السودان كافه ان الدم السوداني
غالي وان لابد ان نعمل جميعا على معالجه
هذه الازمه بالحوار وعيدا عن السلاح لان
السلاح لا يحل شيء ولن يفضي الى سواء مزيد
من الدمار ومسيد من الابرياء يسقطون
فنتجه الى الحوار نتجه الى معالجه الامور
من خلاله ونمتنع عن تعريض المدنيين الى
الخطر باستمرار هذا القتال بذات انه
القتال في المناطق المدنيه وانا واثق ان
الاخوه في السودان
سيتحملون مسؤولياتهم وسيقومون بما يجب
لتجريب المواطن السوداني مزيد من الدمار
والخراب ومره اخرى سنعمل مع اصدقائنا في
امريكا وكافه شركائنا في المنطقه
واخرون للدفع في هذا الاتجاه
منذ نهائي امريكا لاطول حرب من اننا
سنستمر بالتركيز
على مصالحنا للامن القومي لمن عمليات
الارهاب الناجمه عن افغانستان ضرورين سوف
نتصرف ونعمل على التعامل معها وقد اظهرنا
ذلك بشكل جليل في الاشرقيه قدرتنا على فعل
ذلك من ضمنها التخلص من احد كبار قياداتي
القاعده الذي يسكن في افغانستان او يقوم
في افغانستان نحن نعمل مشاركة ودول الجوار
لتعزيز القدرات التعامل مع اي عمله
ترهابيه قد يكون مقرها في افغانستان
او تنجم من هناك وفي نفس الوقت
الطالب عنه
عدو لدعى خراسان
ويعمل ضد هذه الجماعه وبغض النظر عن ذلك
فقد اوضحنا
اظهرنا قدراتنا المستمره للقيام باعمال
تحمي امننا ضد اي ارهاب قد ينجم من
افغانستان
البصمه امريكا العسكريه المنخفضه في كل
منطقه الوفره الفرص للصين لتعزيز علاقاتهم
على المملكه العربيه السعوديه واخرين
ثانيا ام متقد لعاده الاندماج لسوريا
للمنطقه قال بان بشار الاسد نفعل شيء
الاستحقاق ذلك حل
حدثت العربيه السعوديه شروط مقابله عوده
السعوديه لاحظ العربيه الوزير بلانكا هل
تخشون ان الصين
يعتمد عليها اكثر من امريكا في المنطقه
وفيما يخص سوريا امريكا
طلبه الدول التي طبعت علاقاتها ان تحصل
اشياء بمقابل التطبيعها مع الاسد حل ان
جمع التطبيعة عن اي تنازلات
ثانيه اكبر اقتصاد في العالم وهي اكبر
الشركه التجاري بشكل طبيعي هنا الكثير من
التفاعلات والتعامل مع الصين لانها شريكه
هام للمملكه
ولاغلب الدوليه المنطقه واعتقد بان هذه
الشراكه
وفرت لنا ولا الصين فائده كثيره وهذا
التعاون على اكثر سينمو بسبب باثر الصله
الاقتصادي على المنطقه لانه ايضا مع زياده
الصين ولكن الاعزاء الذين شراكه انديه
قويه مع امريكا وهذه الشراكه الامنيه
نعيد تجديدها وانعاشات كل يوم تقريبا
ولدينا تمارين عسكريه مستمره ولدينا
التعاون مشاركه معلومات الاستخباراتيه كما
نرى في الجهود في السودان
في اليمن هذه الشراكه تبقى قويه خاصه في
تلك المجالات والمناطق فانا
لا اقول بانها هي لعبه نحن قادرون تكوين
شراكات وتفاعلات متعدده و امريكا تفعل نفس
الشيء في حالات عديده
السلبيه فنحن نستطيع ان نبي شراكه تتجاوز
هذه
وقد سمعت بيانات من امريكا حول الرغبه
لايجاد السبل لتعاون افضل حتى مع الصين
ذلك لا نشجع ذلك لاننا نرى ان
التعاونك المستقبل وهذا يعني التعاون بين
الجميع فيما يخص سوريا من المهم جدا ان
ندرك السياق السياق
حواء ان الوضع الراهن لم يكن ناجحا وكان
والده عبء المتزايد على دول المنطقه وعلى
الشعب السوري بغض النظر عما عن وجهه نظر
اتجاهها بشار الاسد ان المسار الوحيد لحل
التحديات الانسانيه التي نواجهها في
الازمه السوريه هي لايجاد المسار لمعالجه
مشاكل اساسيه
والمخافه الاخرى وكيف نضمن وجود مسار امن
لعوده اللاجئين
ووجود بعض اله التسويه
السياسيه او مشكله المخدرات كل هذه الامور
تتطلب الحوار مع دمشق
ربما قراتم البيان بعد اجتماعنا في عمان
قبل العوده الى جمع الدول العربيه واوضح
اقدم السوريه التزامات واضحه جدا في كل
تلك المجالات العامله معنا ومعالجتها بشكل
يلبي امال ليس فقط
حتى المجتمع الدولي
والان سوف نعمل على شكل الالتزامات التي
قدمتها دمشق في الختم يجب ان يفكر في
المساله الانسانيه والشعب السوري
وكيف ان نرفع عنهم المعاناه التي يعيشونها
ونحن نؤمن بان هذا وافضل مسار قدما اما
الجهد الاخرى فقد
فشلت عن تحقيق اي تقدم على مدى السنوات
وفقط زادت صعوبه الاوضاع مثلا لبنان الذي
يعيشه بضاعه الاقتصاديه صعبه جدا
فليس
سوري لا استطيع التحمل هذه اللعبه طويلا
يجب ان نتجنب الوضع الذي يضعهم في خطر في
امان نحن نؤمن بان هذا المسار قد ينجم
ويمكن ان ينجم على التاج
بينما فشلت الجهود الاخرى نحن نعمل مع
امريكا واخرون
كلها ضمن اعمل المجتمع الدولي
التماشيا مع قرار المجلس الامن الذي له
الصلاه بالامر
فيما يخص الصين
بمطابق تماما اللي جواب مع علي الوزير
الخارجيه اولا اتفقنا في المنطقه
وشراكاتنا وعملنا هنا لا يدور
او علاقه بدوله اخرى بل له علاقه بهذه
الشركات والمصالح من خلال العمل معا
شعوبنا
ونستطيع حتى تحديدا نقدمها للشعب العالم
وقد وصفت بعضها مسبقا وفي نفس الوقت بشكل
خاص فيما يخص الصين
لقد اوضحنا اننا لا نطلب لاي طرف ان يختار
بين الولايات المتحده او الصين فقط نحاول
ان نظهر
فوائد شراكتنا
والاجندن
الحاسمه التي نقدمها ومنحاول فعله
وكل ما سمعته على مدى العامين ونصف
الماضيين وحتى الايام الثلاثه الماضيه من
الشركاء حول المنطقه والعديد منهم كانوا
حاضرين هنا في رياض الولايات المتحده تبقى
الشركه المفضله لاغلب دول المنطقه
فيما يخص سوريا
مره اخرى ليس سرا نحن لم نعتقد
بان اعاده اندماج سوريا الدول العربيه
كانت صحيحا ولكن في نفس الوقت نحن نرى بان
اهدافنا متشابهه فيما نحاول تحقيقه موقفنا
واضح جدا
لن نطبع العلاقات مع الاسد ومع هذا النظام
لانه لم يستحق هذه الخطوه تجاه الاعتراف
بها القبول به
ولكن
لان الاهداف متطابقه تقريبا فاعتقدوا بان
من اجل مضيق ودوما وكما وصف مع الوزير
الخارجيه فربما سنحقق بعض التقدم وكلنا
نرى بالتواصل الى حل في سوريا
يتطابقون مع قرارات مجلس الامن 22 54
ونوسع امكانيه الوصول لمساعدات الانسانيه
الى الشعب السوري ونضمن عدم
بروزي 11 مره اخرى ونريد الظروف الامنه
لعوده اللاجئين
ومكافحه تهريبي مخدرات التي تسبب باضرار
كبيره في المنطقه وتقليل نفوذ الايراني
فما سمعنا وما سمعتموه مره اخرى من الوزير
الخارجيه هو نيه شركائنا لاستغلال يتفاعل
مباشر مع نظام الاسد من اجل تحقيق المزيد
من التقدم في هذه المجالات ومجالات اخرى
خلال الاشهر القادمه
اننا متشككون من رغبه الاسد في اتخاذ
الخطوات اللازمه ولكننا متوائمون مع
شركائنا هنا حول ما هي تلك الخطوات وحول
الاهداف النهائيه
شكرا جزيلا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات